I didn't even get a chance to talk about this
yesterday, but it's absolutely baffling and
disgusting.
At his rally on Saturday night, Donald Trump
came out violently against the First Amendment
to the Constitution of the United States.
Donald Trump said in Tulsa on Saturday night
that, by the way, stop e-mailing me, saying
it's I know it's Tulsa.
Come on.
We're just having a good time.
Trump said on Saturday night that he wants
flag burning to be punishable by a year in
prison, despite the fact that the Supreme
Court has said multiple times flag burning
is a protected activity.
You can't punish people for burning a flag.
It's a type of speech.
Check it out.
Check out Donald Trump's.
Audience cheering for this supposed constitutional
conservatives cheering for the attempted destruction
of the First Amendment by their dear leader,
who they will, of course, unquestioningly
vote for in November.
Take a look.
Two days ago, leftist radicals in Portland,
Oregon, ripped down a statue.
Of George Washington.
And wrapped it in an American flag and set
the American flag on fire.
Democrat, all Democrat.
Everything I tell you is Democrat.
And, you know, we ought to do something, Mr.
Senators, we have two great senators.
We ought to come up with legislation that
if you burn the American flag, you go to jail
for one year, one year.
The crowd not even hesitating.
I mean, so again, so-called conservatives
who support the Constitution cheering for
Trump, suggesting we punish a constitutionally
protected activity with a year in prison.
Now, it's also important that I want to focus
on the flag burning, but there's also a deliberate
conflation that Trump does.
Trump starts by talking about tearing down
a statue.
But then he says burning the flag should be
punishable by a year in prison.
Tearing down a statue can be a property crime.
Right.
That's it.
That's a very different thing than constitutionally
protected speech.
Burning a flag, stomping on a flag that is
not only not a crime.
It's specifically protected activity.
It's a form of speech protected by the First
Amendment.
And this is not an obscure legal decision
like that.
This is wide legal precedent, widely known
legal precedent.
The Supreme Court decided in 1989 in Texas
v. Johnson, and it reaffirmed it in 1990 in
U.S. v. Eichmann or Eichmann, that any prohibitions
on so-called desecration of flags are unconstitutional.
It's just flat out unconstitutional, burning
a flag as a form of speech.
It's symbolic speech.
Burning American flags is a form of speech
in protest movements that go back a long time.
So what Trump is asking for and what his audience
is ravenously cheering for, it is unconstitutional.
Will his followers care that Trump is proposing
something unconstitutional?
No, mostly they won't.
You've got actual principled constitutional
conservatives.
Now, when I say principled, I don't mean I
agree with their views.
But what I mean is they don't abandon their
principles when Trump says the opposite and
then cheer it the way people in the crowd
are doing.
They are sometimes coming out like George
Will has come out and said he's got to go.
Trump's got to go.
I don't really agree with George Will on on
most things, but George Will at least abides
by the principles he has identified as being
important to him.
And that includes that what's in the Constitution,
at least as he sees it, matters now.
It's important, I think, to mention there
are limitations on flag burning, like you
can't go on to a neighbor's property and drop
a burning flag on their wooden porch.
Right.
But that's not the flag burning that's illegal
there.
It's the trespassing and the arson.
Whether you drop, you know, papers or a burning
flag, if anything's if you do that, there
are other crimes you are committing.
But that's not what we're talking about here.
We're talking about just the burning of a
flag.
Trump kept going, calling for exactly the
type of legislation that the Supreme Court
has already said multiple times is unconstitutional.
Take a look.
We should have legislation that if somebody
wants to burn the American flag and stomp
on it, but just burn it, they go to jail for
one year.
OK.
This is what I called dumb red meat.
We talk about red meat and dog whistles in
in American politics and and Republicans very
often throw them out.
This is dumb red meat.
And Trump has actually been using this dumb
red meat for a long time.
Here's just one video of Trump from 2016.
You'll notice, by the way, sounding far more
articulate, saying something similar about
flag burning.
See people ripping up the American flag like
that flag.
Beautiful.
When I see I think it's a disgrace.
OK.
As you can say what you want, free speech.
It's all wonderful.
Everything's wonderful.
I'm a big believer in free speech.
But maybe we're going to be putting something
in to see if we can do something about it,
because this is a special case.
And when I see people burning the American
flag and then stepping on it as it's burning
up and then stomping on it and stepping on
it on the ground, I don't think I don't think
in the I don't think I remember that when
I was growing dissent.
Right.
How many of you guys are young like me?
Remember when we were very young?
I don't remember that happening.
Yeah.
So dumb red meat, it fires people up, but
it also sort of confuses them since they thought
they were for free speech and that they were
for the Constitution.
I guess they thought Trump was also for those
things.
And then Trump comes out with a year in prison
for burning the flag.
So understand, I guess the takeaway is, first
of all, this didn't get nearly enough attention.
This is the president saying cancel the First
Amendment, at least the part of it that he
doesn't like, but understand how backwards
things are that we have a White House that
dropped the ball on Corona virus.
Trump admitted he wanted to reduce testing
early on so that he would look better.
We have protests against vile police brutality.
We have nearly 20 percent real unemployment
rate.
And the controversies that Trump wants to
focus on are do people kneel during the anthem
or not?
And did somebody burn a flag?
It's not just transparent.
It's actually pathetic, because as I said
yesterday, he has no case.
He has no coherent case for why he should
be reelected.
And so he's talking about flag burning and
kneeling during protests, kneeling, dühring
kneeling, kneeling during the national anthem
in sports as well.
It's fully authoritarian.
It's also really dumb.
And hopefully this country is never in a place
where flag burning seriously has a chance
at becoming criminalized, even under the relatively
conservative Supreme Court that we have right
now.
I don't see any way that there's any shot
at flag burning being criminalized, as it
should be.
Let me know your thoughts.
I am on Twitter at David Pakman.
Remember that you can subscribe for free to
the Daily David Pakman Show audio podcast.
It's the earliest if you look at all the things
we publish, Facebook clips, YouTube clips,
et cetera.
The earliest thing to publish is the daily
audio podcast, which is available for free
on I, iTunes, Stitcher, Google Play, Pandora,
I Heart Radio Speaker, Pod being Spotify.
As you can tell, it's too available at this
point really.